questo questo video questo video questo
video non volevo farlo però è anche
giusto che voi capiate un attimino la
situazione perché è grave ai ragazzi ho
24 anni ho finito la scuola nel 2014
madonna sono passati sei anni da quando
ho preso il diploma
porca vacca non sono mai stato bocciato
tranne alla patente
ho frequentato uniti su un tecnico
informatico questo qua è il mio diploma
non vi ho mai parlato di queste cose
perché la mia scuola non l'ho mai voluta
mettere in mezzo perché perché andavo di
merda e se vi riprova ragazzi allora vi
sono diplomato nel ma ce l'hanno
ritrovato nel 2014 questo è il vostro
foto con cui sono uscito un bel 60 e
ringraziando a cristo perché in realtà
neanche quello mi meritavo però ragazzi
allora il discorso in alto visto che me
lo chiedete spesso oggi vi faccio vedere
il mio pagellino delle superiori però
non è un vero e proprio pagellino
diciamo che noi avevamo questi questi
libretti scolastici dove segnavamo i
volti o che adesso voi magari siete
tecnologici c'avete la roba computer
noi facevamo un tecnico informatico la
carta allora partiamo con questo che del
2009 mi è cascato qualcosa alla mia
tessera
meno male che mi è cascata
fortunatamente ne ho anche un sacco
quindi ragazzi se siete interessati
vendo tessera da malvivente allora
questa è la libretto del 2009 quindi il
primo anno di superiori quindi il primo
anno di superiori è iniziato il mio
inferno il libretto è diviso così ogni
pagina c'è una materia con tutti i volti
segnati a questa è la pagina di italiano
io in italiano me la sono sempre cavata
abbastanza bene perché non so lo so
ragazzi in realtà però a scrivere temi
ste robe me la sono sempre abbastanza
cavata nelle materie umanistiche anche
storia non era niente male
qua c'è un 3 però anche vedi geografia
8.000 non sono niente male nelle materie
umanistiche però ho fatto informatica
siccome il tecnico si fa tutta
matematica tutta tutte robe algebrica
eccetera io in matematica faccio pagare
che cosa ho scelto scelte di fare
informatiche di un genio questa invece
era inglese inglese anche me la cavavo
abbastanza bene in realtà vedete tutti
questi 676 sarebbero potuti essere 9 10
semplicemente l'ing io l'inglese lo
sapevo già
senza studiarlo se avessi studiato avrei
preso anche 9 10 ma ero pigro quindi 7 6
7 passiamo ragazzi a scienze scienze
alla materia molto bella
l'anno scolastico è partito con il treno
è stato proprio vi ricordo che eravamo
io e il mio migliore amico che si chiama
gabriele e eravamo io e lui siamo dello
stesso paesino viviamo abbiamo fatto
elementari medie e superiori insieme ci
conosciamo da 6000 anni abbiamo fatto le
superiori se stessa classe prima
verifica di scienze mi arriva la
consegna prima a me 3 la guardo tutti
gli atti avevano preso 65 67 quindi
abbastanza bene
aria mentre affranti simo la guardo e
dico che continua a fissarlo arriva il
mio amico anche lui aveva preso tre
eravamo gli unici due ripreso tre gli
unici due aver fatto così ski promo io e
lui arriva lui 3 e io lo sento dire
dall'altra parte dell'asp della classe
lo sento dire e io ho detto è sì e prof
e quello che ho pensato io mi hanno
avuto il coraggio di dire
fantastico ho la mia amata matematica
che tra l'altro tra l'altro non andava
neanche così male 55 più sei e mezzo se
invece 5 mezzo 66 più tremezzo 47 al
lotto si vede proprio che questo è il
primo anno lo aspettate che vi leggo gli
altri libretti ma questa fortuna
pubblicata sulle storie
qualche giorno fa matematica allora
abbiamo bellissimo uno ne avesse uno tra
l'altro io il professore di matematica
che avevo e lo adoravo ci sarai preso a
testate del corso di matematica
il professore di matematica che avevo
era il mio prof preferito vi giuro io vi
giuro che è matematica era una di quelle
poche materie che io avevo sotto perché
ero stupito ma non perché il proprio non
sapeva in sei perché alle volte è colpa
di giugno alla volta è colpa dei prof
e io quando è colpa dei propri lo dico è
colpa del proprio non sa fare una sega
perché alcuni non hanno un insegnano la
propria materia con passione eccetera la
fanno pesare come se fosse la morte
alcuni proprio mettono i voti a caso
altri invece mettono i botti come si
deve questo di matematicamente ai conti
come si deve era semplicemente ero io
che facevo schifo ma lo ammetto quando
c'è da ammetterlo lo ammetto in
matematica faceva cagare e mi dispiaceva
un sacco perché il mio proprio a mi sta
simpaticissimo e lui mi diceva pure il
play guastoni una sufficienza ti prendi
riceve prof
poi c'era la mia prof di informatica che
se voi analizzate tutto l'anno
scolastico
ok sapete che tutto l'anno scolastico
vedrete che non esiste una sufficienza
se non questa sopra il mio pollice che
era sempre di laboratorio quindi non
dipendeva da me m'ha scritto e orale io
in tutto l'anno non ho preso una
sufficienza e non perché no alle volte
non me la meritavo davvero altre volte
diciamo che sarà una di quelle preghiera
io avevo due o tre professori in tutto
il tecnico e proprio fatto avevo due o
tre professori che mettevano voti a caso
vedevano chi eri e ti mettevano il voto
giuro due o tre erano così e poi c'era
elettronica elettronica fantastica
perché sono partito con un 5 45 che
sembra una formazione di calcio e poi il
quadrimestre dopo fatot mezzo 85 mezzo 3
3 e mezzo sette e mezzo
non ho idea del motivo era il tab però
perfetto questa invece la mia profili
statistica che era talmente pigro che
non firmava neanche quando mi metteva i
bot
vediamo l'ultimo dato è il doppio questo
qua perché era l'ultimo anno e
nell'ultimo anno avevo fatto tipo avevo
raggiunto il massimo di assenze
ero a rischio per questo motivo perché
l'ultimo anno io ho fatto l'ultimo anno
di scuola io facevo già youtube facevo
già i video se voi guardate i video di
fare i j nel 2013 2014 usciti nel 2003
2013 2014 io andavo all'ultimo anno di
scuola e quindi tante volte stavo
sveglio una nota che io andavo a scuola
tornavo a casa registravo il video
montavo il video dopo cena più o meno e
poi andavo a dormire le volte le 3 e le
4 del mattino perché per montare il
video io facevo orari veramente
imbarazzanti non era colpa mia che i
video sono veramente difficile ammontare
almeno lo erano all'inizio tantissimo
perché all'inizio dovevo stiller neanche
quel programma
quindi per tenere il mio lavoro e la
scuola facevo degli orari interminabili
e andavo a scuola con tipo tra quattro
ore di sonno o la mia amatissima
matematica ma quest'anno dato molta più
soddisfazione al mio prof di matematica
avevo dato in quinta guardate un po
quest'anno incredibile perché
addirittura ho preso un 6 più bellissimo
belli quest'anno questa penso sia la più
brutta pagina di tutte elettronica e
telecomunicazioni elettronica e
telecomunicazioni dell'ultimo anno
allora diciamo che è una materia che a
me ha sempre fatto cagare ok perché
sceglie il tecnico perché vorrei fare
informatica cio scelto da chi dovevo
fare informatica tra i vari indirizzi
del tecnico c'era anche elettronica tu
potevi fare informatica elettronica e
areonautica che cazzo c'entra però
effettivamente po di fare queste tre
cose io ho scelto informatiche quindi a
me dell'elettronica me ne sbatte vale
balle però è giusto che ti facciano
un'infarinatura di elettronica perché
comunque se fai informatica ci sta che
tu sappia anche dell'elettronica ma
faceva talmente schifo che non riuscivo
proprio a non capivo niente
sicuramente l'aver fatto lo youtuber non
ha aiutato perché comunque mi toglieva
tantissimo tempo ma io mi sono sempre
reso conto di avere una pessima memoria
ok ti faccio questo discorso finale non
è per giustificarmi non ero bravo a
scuola in quelle matematiche in quelle
umanistiche
lungi da me voler di far trasparire
chissà poi quale messaggio non c'è
niente in questo video è fine a se
stesso e non è passati alcun messaggio
però io ho sempre notato che le persone
che andavano bene nella mia classe ma
non del tecnico in generale proprio
elementari medie e nata nella vita di
tutti i giorni erano dei trogloditi però
andavano bene perché perché avevano una
buona memoria o perché avevano una buona
capacità di memorizzazione delle cose
cioè loro magari stavano stando attenti
riuscivano a memorizzare determinate
cose che io non riuscivo a memorizzare
perché io noto nella mia vita noto di
avere questo problema
attenzione quando una persona mi parla
se non mi interessa l'argomento di cui
mi sta parlando
che non vuol dire che mi annoia e
semplicemente non è la cosa che voglio
sentire in quel momento non mi rimane
niente di quello che mi sta dice ma
niente c'è proprio di zero il mio
cervello non assorbe nulla di quello che
sta dicendo con la persona questo è
grave problema perché nella scuola conta
tanto la memoria c'è gente che c'è la
memoria fotografica per il libro tutto a
memoria ok e gava fanku però io non ce
l'ho mai avuta sta cosa io dovevo
rileggere una pagina 60 volte è ancora
non me la ricordavo
sono orgoglioso di essere uscito dalla
mia scuola senza mai essere bocciato che
guardando i voti è già difficile però se
posso proprio dirlo è stato un inferno
pensate che ancora ogni tanto me la
signora notte un po come i militari che
sognano la guerra uguale duro io la
notte bisogna ancora le volte che sono
ancora in quinta devo fare tutta la
quinta orribile che quando mi sveglio e
sempre un paradiso però quel momento
mentre faccio quell'incubo è orribile
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto questa
era la mia capacità di intellettuale
scolastica saluto tutti gli eletti prof
con amore e soprattutto quello di
matematica che gli volevo bene re
l'anima mi dispiace non ti ho mai dato
di fatto non le ho mai la mi scusi ormai
dato soddisfazione prof mi scusi ma con
il cuore veramente l'eroe un sacco
vicino con il cuore ho preso 10 con il
cervello
no quando ho preso uno sono dove gli ho
detto prof per favore mi mette almeno 21
studi quanto ti devo mettere pace e
amore a tutti bella ragazzi
[Musica]